BARTON ZWIEBACH: We
were faced last time
with a question
of interpretation
of the Schrodinger
wave function.
And so to recap the main
ideas that we were looking at,
we derive this
Schrodinger equation,
basically derived it
from simple ideas--
having operators, energy
operator, momentum operator,
and exploring how the de
Broglie wavelength associated
to a particle would be a wave
that would solve the equation.
And the equation was the
Schrodinger equation,
a free Schrodinger
equation, and then
we added the
potential to make it
interacting and that way,
we motivated the Schrodinger
equation and took this form
of x and t psi of x and t.
And this is a dynamical equation
that governs the wave function.
But the interpretation
that we've
had for the wave function,
we discussed what Born said,
was that it's related
to probabilities
and psi squared
multiplied by a little dx
would give you the
probability to find
the particle in that little
dx at some particular time.
So psi of x and t squared
dx would be the probability
to find the particle at
that interval dx around x.
And if you're describing the
physics of your Schrodinger
equation is that of
a single particle,
which is the case here--
one coordinate, the coordinate
of the particle, this integral,
if you integrate
this all over space,
must be 1 for the
probability to make sense.
So the total probability of
finding the particle must be 1,
must be somewhere.
If it's in one part
of another part
or another part, this
probabilities-- for this
to be a probability
distribution,
it has to be well-normalized,
which means 1.
And we said that this equation
was interesting but somewhat
worrisome, because if the
normalization of the wave
function satisfies, if this
holds for t equal t-nought
then the Schrodinger equation,
if you know the wave function
all over space for t equal
t-nought, which is what you
would need to know in order
to check that this is working,
a t equal t-nought, you take
the psi of x and t-nought,
integrate it.
But if you know psi of x
and t-nought for all x,
then the Schrodinger
equation tells you
what the wave function
is at a later time.
Because it gives you the
time derivative of the wave
function in terms of
data about the wave
function all over space.
So automatically, the
Schrodinger equation
must make it true that this
will hold at later times.
You cannot force the wave
function to satisfy this at all
times.
You can force it maybe
to satisfy at one time,
but once it satisfies it at
this time, then it will evolve,
and it better be that
at every time later,
it still satisfies
this equation.
So this is a very
important constraint.
So we'll basically develop this
throughout the lecture today.
We're going to make a big point
of this trying to explain why
the conditions that we're going
to impose on the wave function
are necessary; what it teaches
you about the Hamiltonian,
we'll teach you that it's
a Hermitian operator;
what do you learn
about probability--
you will learn that there
is a probability current;
and all kinds of things will
come out of taking seriously
the interpretation
of this probability,
the main point being that
we can be sure it behaves
as a probability at one time,
but then for later times,
the behaviors and probability
the Schrodinger equation must
help--
must somehow be part of
the reason this works out.
So that's what we're
going to try to do.
Now, when we write an equation
like this, and more explicitly,
this means integral of psi star
of x and t, psi of x and t dx
equal 1.
You can imagine that not
all kind of functions
will satisfy it.
In particular, any wave
function, for example,
that at infinity approaches
a constant will never
satisfy this, because
if infinity, you
approach a constant,
then the integral
is going to be infinite.
And it's just not
going to work out.
So the wave function cannot
approach a finite number,
a finite constant as
x goes to infinity.
So in order for this to hold--
order to guarantee this can
even hold, can conceivably hold,
it will require a bit
of boundary conditions.
And we'll say that
the limit as x
goes to infinity
or minus infinity--
plus/minus infinity of psi of
x and t will be equal to 0.
It better be true.
And we'll ask a little more.
Now, you could say,
look, certainly
the limit of this
function could not
be in number, because it
would be non-zero number,
the interval will diverge.
But maybe there is no limit.
The wave function is so crazy
that it can be integrated,
but suddenly, it
has a little spike
and it just doesn't
have a normal limit.
That could conceivably
be the case.
Nevertheless, it doesn't seem
to happen in any example that
is of relevance.
So we will assume that
the situations are not
that crazy that this happened.
So we'll take wave
functions that necessarily
go to 0 at infinity.
And that certainly is good.
You cannot prove it's
a necessary condition,
but if it holds, it
simplifies many, many things,
and essentially, if the wave
function is good enough to have
a limit, then the
limit must be 0.
The other thing
that we will want
is that d psi/dx, the limit as
x goes to plus/minus infinity
is bounded.
That is, yes, the limit may
exist and it may be a number,
but it's not infinite.
And In every example
that I know of--
in fact, when this goes to
0, this goes to 0 as well--
but this is basically all
you will ever need in order
to make sense of the wave
functions and their integrals
that we're going to be doing.
Now you shouldn't
be too surprised
that you need to say something
about this wave function
in the analysis
that will follow,
because the derivative--
you have the function
and its derivative,
because certainly, there
are two derivatives here.
So when we manipulate
these quantities
inside the integrals,
you will see very soon--
single derivatives will show up
and we'll have to control them.
So the only thing
that I'm saying
is that when you see
a wave function that
satisfies this
property, you know
that unless the function
is extremely crazy,
it's a function that goes
to 0 at plus/minus infinity.
And it's the relative
pursuant it also goes to 0,
but it will be enough to say
that it maybe goes to a number.
Now there's another
possibility thing for confusion
here with things that
we've been saying before.
We've said before that the
physics of a wave function
is not altered by multiplying
the wave function by a number.
We said that psi added to
psi is the same state; psi
is the same state as
square root of 2 psi--
all this is the same
physics, but here it
looks a little surprising if you
wish, because if I have a psi
and I got this
already working out,
if I multiply psi by square
root of 2, it will not hold.
So there seems to be a little
maybe something with the words
that we're been using.
It's not exactly
right and I want
to make sure there is no
room for confusion here,
and it's the following fact.
Here, this wave function
has been normalized.
So there's two kinds of wave
functions that you can have--
wave functions that can be
normalized and wave functions
that cannot be normalized.
Suppose somebody comes to you
and gives you a psi of x and t.
Or let's assume that--
I'll put x and t.
No problem.
Now suppose you go and
start doing this integral--
integral of psi squared dx.
And then you find that
it's not equal to 1
but is equal to
some value N, which
is different from 1 maybe.
If this happens, we say that
psi is normalizable, which
means it can be normalized.
And using this idea that
changing the value--
the coefficient
of the function--
doesn't change too
much, we simply say, use
instead psi prime, which
is equal to psi over
square root of N. And look what
a nice property this psi prime
has.
If you integrate psi prime
squared, it would be equal--
because you have psi
prime here is squared,
it would be equal to the
integral of PSI squared divided
by the number N--
because there's two of them--
dx, and the number goes out and
you have the integral of psi
squared dx, but that integral
was exactly N, so that's 1.
So if your wave function
has a finite integral
in this sense, a number
that is less than infinity,
then psi can be normalized.
And if you're going to
work with probabilities,
you should use instead
this wave function,
which is the original wave
function divided by a number.
So they realize
that, in some sense,
you can delay all of
this and you can always
work with wave functions
that are normalizable,
but only when you're going to
calculate your probabilities.
You can take the trouble
to actually normalize them
and those are the ones
you use in these formulas.
So the idea remains that we work
flexibly with wave functions
and multiply them by numbers and
nothing changes as long as you
realize that you cannot change
the fact that the wave function
is normalizable by multiplying
it by any finite number,
it will still be normalized.
And if it's normalizable, it's
equivalent to a normalized wave
function.
So those two words
sound very similar,
but they're a little different.
One is normalizable, which
means it has an integral of psi
squared finite, and
normalize is one
that already has been
adjusted to do this
and can be used to define
a probability distribution.
OK.
So that, in a way
of introduction
to the problem
that we have to do,
our serious problem
is indeed justifying
that the time evolution doesn't
mess up the normalization
and how does it do that?